Maori order
to foreign
Maori
this week and I thought it was
appropriate we should open
that way for those
who care what I was doing is welcoming
you with the Breath of Life offering
greetings to the building
greetings to the ground outside
greetings to the people of this area
A Farewell to those who've passed
and turning to greet those who are
living
so hello to all in this room and on the
live stream
greetings to you all
open the meeting of the community
wellbeing committee for Tuesday the 12th
for those that have been waiting our
apologies but the council meeting did go
a little longer than expected but that's
why the start time was written down as
at the conclusion of the extraordinary
council meeting
we have apologies from Mrs coote and
councilor crackett although councilor
crackett is attending by Zoom
uh would somebody like to move that
that's accepted Barry and Trish put that
all in favor
um against
carried
uh there are no items in the public
forum that I'm aware of
I'll welcome our youth council members
so Liam called her Emma Pope and Emma
Wills if you'd like to come and
grab a seat
this is tab seven on your minutes
welcome along to the meeting thanks for
giving up time to come along we do
appreciate it
councilors mayor and maniferua Reps my
name is Emma wills and I'm here today to
speak
Egyptians passed by Council around
climate change
to better involve youth we need to be
included in decision making if there is
anything specific you would like our
ideas on we would prefer involving those
passionate about climate change in a
council Workshop
and really delve into specifics with you
it would be preferable for us to engage
in a planned one-off conversation rather
than for us to provide smaller comments
throughout the year
an example that fits into our idea
around
signage has already been implemented by
parks with their low-mo information
signs we want to see Council focusing on
the good news stories and positive
information
changes do not need to be massive it
would just be good to see steps forward
in the right direction
when it comes to focusing on Greener
practices we were pleased to hear that
environmental options are being chosen
chosen with public parades
opposed to foil streamers which usually
make up a ticker tape parade
and I'm here to speak on The Vaping
section of this report
the community and the community advocacy
and volunteering committee is a device
and have many different insights around
vaping our committee felt there is a
strong uptake in vaping with peers
across all schools
a course of this is social pressure to
Vape in school bathrooms
this feeling was backed up with
two-thirds of our reports being
introduced to vaping from piers and
nearly half receiving new products from
peers
I called her of resp respondents Vape
daily and 15.25
15.25 of respondents Vape weekly month
slash monthly with the majority starting
at Social its force with majority
standing for social reasons
their average age for those
surveying was they
sorry the average age of those surveyed
was 16 with the youngest being eight
the youngest being eight we found the
information to be very concerning we
believe in expansion of the smoke-free
CBD boundary would support smoke free
2025 and what our survey has uncovered
this expansion may include school zones
it would be useful to see more
smoke-free and vape free science signage
within the CBD and would be good to see
the awareness of smoke-free zones
following onto council's social media
and platforms
some respondents comments
that the committee thought stood out
included being afraid of
entering school bathrooms due to vaping
and being offered Vapes at school
many had fears of their peers Health
with one report saying they will have a
lot of funerals to attend soon many
respondents who did Vape commit
committed the health had declined since
but the beginning since beginning vaping
and felt they still couldn't quit
youth Council are interested to know
what the measures exist when especially
when specialist sorry when specialized
vape stores wants to to be open in an
ICC smoke-free policy Zone
that's all right on a lighter note my
name is Liam Calder and I'm very excited
to announce that youth Council will be
opening its nominations this Friday for
the 2024 youth council elections
we
we are hoping to get applications far
and wide this year with some outstanding
Graphics of our Council mascot Dwight
the duck
now Dwight traveled with me to
Wellington to the Festival of the future
and we have some
good and bad photos together
uh we're looking at new processes to
gain more attraction hence Dwight
um uh which we were hoping to share
which was in your last Community
well-being committee report uh
nominations close uh Sunday the 15th of
October so make sure to tell the 12 to
24 year olds in your life that youth
council is gearing up for another year
and we would love to have them here for
a ride uh you too uh Chris youth
counselors this year have you guys found
it thoroughly enjoyed it yeah loved it
so that's all from me
right excellent and that was a very
vibrant challenge too I thought you were
asking us if we're going to join for a
second there Liam no word until I heard
the age criteria
realize that nobody fitted
[Laughter]
um on a serious note thank you for your
challenge around climate change we have
heard how you wish to be engaged and
it's really useful and brave of you to
to tell us so thank you for that and
interesting feedback as well on um on
vaping and some concerning uh statistics
um before I cast out to the councilors
you suggested that we look at expanding
our smoke-free boundary from within the
CBD if smoke-free New Zealand 2025 is 18
months away
is that a useful thing to do
um well I I personally I believe it is
because the faster we can stop or
prevent people
from vaping the better
cool
Grant
yeah thanks chin welcome and it's always
great to have you people here to just
hear your voice I think you share a
valuable perspective so thanks for
coming
um just with your public awareness piece
on social media so what what is the best
way to engage with youth what type of
social media
um I use using to get their information
and how do we as Council connect to them
in a meaningful way that you know if we
think of the museum or so think of some
of the projects we're bringing forward
or we just want to hear their voice what
is the best social media channel to
communicate with youth or receive
information from youth in your
perspective so from your peers or
is it Facebook
and the museum video was a really good
example of it engaging in it was very
vibrant as it was a really cool video
that was made and it had an awesome flow
through the whole video so those are
things that engage us and just yeah
thought-provoking words as well yeah
because I know a couple of councils went
down to one of the schools and a lot of
those kids knew nothing about the museum
project
so that worries me that we're not
communicating or connecting with those
kids
sorry young people you know so this is
High School
I think more opening it up to
a younger range
I think a lot of people go oh it's
Museum Council staff that's not really
me is it just because it's some of the
big words that they can understand or it
just doesn't interest them so maybe
including an element that does interest
them just find out what engages people
well well so the internet product sorry
achievement could I put a challenge to
you as
you know
it's a really important project which
I'm leading and it's important project
for a city so in youth Council we're
going to challenge you to think about
how we can communicate the museum story
through social media and you come and
advise us so you'd be the advisors
around it to us and through Lisa and the
comms team so that we are making sure
we're giving ourselves the best
opportunity to connect to you people who
are really important people as a part of
that project
so you'll be Keen to get you thinking
about how to do it and if it's you guys
doing some
um
tick tocks or it's Anita on a tick tock
then I think we're all up for that yeah
good luck with it yeah
Evelyn
um
just really interested in the vaping and
I heard your comment about vape stores
within smoke free CBD and I think the
point is very valid if we we don't
control who people lease to
so obviously there is a limit to how we
can control but the point that you are
making is so important that this is
something that we need to be actually
communicating to the public or is that
how you see it that we're not doing a
good enough job of saying
to the business people of this of who
are within the CBD
what the actual
dissonances between having a smoke-free
CBD and then having businesses that are
actually selling the products that we're
actually trying to exclude from the CBD
cigarette stores in the CBDs cigarette
stores vaping stores and is do you use
in your opinion as young people do you
see that as a contradiction and if so
what do you think we could do to make
those changes
um
uh I do see it as a
with you
how do I wear this um yeah I do see it
with we do see it with
um
the council so the CBD in the vape store
it's just kind of random that um it's
smoke-free but we're allowed shops
promoting this product
um
uh sorry what's the other part of your
question how do you think
you're the you're the the group that
with whom you have some concern you know
uptake as as young as I eat so therefore
what how do you see that the council
could influence what
the business owners within the city
could be doing to help
diminish the outtake of Vape
uh well I don't know if you guys have
any you don't have any control on not
leading vape stores in the CBD do
no yeah so I'd have to talk to my
committee about it and I'll get back to
you about there
thank you
they're meeting tomorrow I'll be here
Trish you will too I see that on YouTube
Liam and Dwight this question for you
um as an educator in the city I know
that Vape
um Vape use it scores rampant what are
you guys doing in your schools to
counterate these
so I'd like you just to take it back
even perhaps with this wonderful new
um group of councilors you're going to
get see if you could develop a campaign
or something because we know it happens
in bathrooms and schools we know and no
school is different
even though they might say it so we
really do need to stop it because it's
creating and bullying issue as well so
if you could come up with some ideas
and even perhaps the Ministry of
Education might be able to help okay
we'll look into that thank you great
good question
Steve uh curate youth Council um I just
had a question just out of Interest what
was your
um mechanic to access the 164 responses
I thought just working in with schools
directly you might have been able to
pull more students so what was the
process there and is there an
opportunity to to get more of a sample
because those are some frightening
statistics but I wonder whether some of
those could be higher
with more people yeah uh so uh youth
count we sent the
code the yeah code to the youth Council
and or uh youth councilors tried their
best to um Sinner and get kids from
schools uh to take the survey so it was
all more of our work so it wasn't like a
we didn't make that many posters or
anything about it it was just more or
similar code around the school still to
our peers yeah repetition was a big
thing which is constantly checking it
out annoying them annoying them and so
just to get them to do it even if you
hadn't done broken just do it we want
those numbers cool
May Clark
so just so that Trish doesn't get off
there throw the comment back to the
students so what is the education
department do around
preventing vaping at school or in in
areas adjoining schools like bus stops
and they've got that
I know it's not the truth
don't have any authority to do anything
at the schools or around that
um apart from the fact that we work with
the schools to discuss strategies
schools need to manage that themselves
ass showing the massive they must have
Ministry guidelines on no we don't have
Ministry guidelines on paper absolutely
and then we give those out to the
schools so they would prohibit
activities at school
you assume I'm not wanting to put you on
send you a copy no I'm just just
wondering being raised as an issue no no
um we definitely do see them to the
schools the schools um and parents who
are concerned about vaping and the
schools not doing anything or what per
se they can find the information
themselves and they can bring it up with
the schools but I know the schools are
trying hard
really difficult
I guess the point that Trish was making
is also their guidelines so they're not
necessarily enforceable or requirements
and we can't
um as Ministry we can't do anything
about
it why not
I guess one of the differences with
vaping is that it's it's far more
discreet than smoking you know you light
a cigarette you're burning it to lend
you know whereas a vape is just
something that's very quick
and I've watched people do it inside
cafes
quickly blow out a cloud
but really interesting to hear some of
those frightening statistics about
especially down the age and where it's
of concern Barry yeah it's always
worried me like with CR City shopping
center and that there's vape shops
everywhere
it seems to be really prevalent the
answer
I don't know what we can do about it we
need to stop them because the Pomona
straight shop
they've rare noted that twice now
you've got a big concrete blocks in
front of it now
I'd love to get rid of them easily
Cura I was also going to ask you about
the vaping
so it was an anonymous online survey
your rangatahi survey and it got 164
responses but I notice a new notes you
said young people tend to see
consequences in speaking out so even
with an anonymous survey
are you indicating there were some young
people who didn't
take part in it because they were
worried about speaking out and the other
thing I saw in your note was that you
said the size and scope was limited and
I only provided an indication so if it
had been a bigger survey would you have
expected a different result
or do you think this is a very good
indication of
of the young people you're dealing with
um
the
countries uh the I do believe if we had
more people
uh take the survey and answer the
questions it would be more
reliable and good yeah
um but I do think that the information
is very valid and it is what's happening
in the community and uh about the
is it
the the oh yeah I will Heaven concerts
of speaking up even though it was an
anonymous survey do you think it was a
factor and some people not responding oh
we did um get really good comments in
some of it but uh there was Parts when
you could tell people were taking the
survey as a joke or not answering the
proper what actually is going on if that
makes sense yeah
so a bigger a bigger survey if you've
got more numbers you'd think it would
have given the same picture of the
problem that the bigger numbers would
have been even more powerful and telling
that story yes yeah 100 yeah thank you
Korea I'm curious and thank you for
presenting to uh Council today just a
couple questions um and yes it's on The
Vaping
um
a newer code was you suggesting that was
a QR code for the survey yeah yeah okay
cool I will see any links to like
um cessation programs on that survey
that people could actually click on
if they wanted to
um help within nicotine addiction
because smoking is a nicotine addiction
so I'm just wondering like
um if you yeah was there a link on that
QR code for cessation programs smoking
water soft smoking vaping uh there
wasn't but it's a good suggestion for
culture yeah yeah
um with with your next presuming that
when you get your fabulous new council
members that you'll run another survey
to improve on areas of like catches and
how you can deliver it
um
have you got a timeline of when you'll
reconsider running another one to kind
of balance and give weight to this first
initial one
uh well our committee has not discussed
that yet so sorry
no that's great
um yeah so I just you know congratulate
you guys for putting this together
um as I said smoking is an absolute
addiction for a whole lot of people in
our country and it seems that
um
the preference now for giving out
smoking is to take up vaping and those
two wrongs don't make it right
Clark then Tom just a couple of quick
things
um I just wonder whether we could help
the youth council with a like we went to
the mall again and went to the mall her
team did um one day and we I think we've
got about five or six hundred going to
the mall and we just asked them a
question could we do the same for Vaping
if we want to increase the
the uptight sorry about that Rihanna
um and the other thing is it was the
issue where vape shops can locate now
we'd have some pretty tight controls
around a liquor outlet on air streak for
argument so
well we we'd have some consideration on
that wouldn't if somebody wanted to open
a shop with it was just liquor well if
it was just liquor then it's a licensing
trust only yeah so what makes me wonder
is that given that we want s Street to
be family friendly and pedestrian
friendly it sort of doesn't sit well
with me that commercially a vape shop
can openly so if there was a new venue
setting up an escalate of the licensing
trust monitor to set up a bottle store
in East Street in that case it would
under the local alcohol policy it would
need to be publicly notified and there
will be the chance for the public to
feed back into it and say no we don't
want that and it has happened in
Riverton yet both are addictive one has
some laws applying and the other one
just
can do it the same with
um legal highs for a while
Tom
your
um
study was essentially a snapshot in time
wasn't it
and it
doesn't really tell us
whether this is an increase in problem
but a decreasing problem and it goes to
I guess Ria's question about whether you
would run another one because that would
be very helpful actually to know whether
this is increasing or decreasing but if
I can tell any equation to you I mean
from you just from your own experience
do you believe and I know it's believed
because you don't have data but but do
do you think that we are seeing an
increase or is it peaked and it's coming
back down again or where do you think we
sit in this epidemic
uh my personal opinion on vaping I think
it is increasing and it's getting worse
and it's sad seeing these kids at school
and just in the city vaping so I think
it's increasing getting worse yeah
and um Regular cycle
I work honey Street and when I first
started at my job I could see the other
side of the street now some days I can
and that's that's the sad fact that it
is increasing
um I don't think we've reached Peak hit
but even in within schools it is a huge
problem
thank you
counselors any other questions or
comments if not I'll move that we
received the report and see if I cancel
a sofa I'll put that all in favor
against Carrie
thank you very much for coming along
Emma Emma and not Emma
um you're interested to know that
actually with all the years that we've
had the youth Council coming along and
presenting to us that we haven't had the
amount of Engagement backwards and
forwards between councilors and the
youth Council that we have had in this
past year so thank you
I think we have a younger Council
[Laughter]
I'm
just hold that one I'll see you tomorrow
I'm taking the duck thank you
counselors that brings us back I'll go
back to Tab four the minutes of the
community well-being fund subcommittee
trash that'll be your committee
do you want to move that they're
received yes please sorry I can see
again so you're gonna grab any questions
comments
if not I'll put the minutes all in favor
against carried
uh minutes of the community well-being
committee from August 8th I'll move
taking the berry
put that all in favor against carried
minutes of the district licensing
committee August meetings
move Peter so you can go to Leslie thank
you any questions
got that all in favor
aye against Kerry that brings us to Tab
8 which is the Sandy Point domain master
plan and management plan
Carolina Chris
[Music]
Sunny Point domain
Japan and management plan paper
um
yeah we've been working on the master
plan for the past two years stroke
covered lockdowns and multiple delays to
actually bringing this to you thank you
for your patience
um now the best way to actually talk you
through or actually demonstrate what the
master plan actually is has come up with
is to go through the presentation which
was an appendix 3 but we've got it on
screen for you here and now
um I go to the okay I like press Drive
Clicker
I just get to talk a little bit about
the um I suppose the executive summary
of The Master Plan it's obviously this
is providing us with a long-term Vision
the next 10 25 and 50 years for the
future use asset renewal development of
Sandy Point it's providing us with a
vision or a road map for how the domain
can be used in the future
um and this master plan is the first
step and it was our first step in the
development and updating the Sandy Point
Reserve management plan which will be
2024 2034.
um it did enable us to engage with many
many different partners across the
community
um which has been an amazing opportunity
for us to have done so and what you're
looking at is a finalized master plan
from that engagement
um moving forward
at the end of this presentation we'll be
looking at the actual management plan
and how we'll have the formal
consultation processes following on from
here but to hand over now to my
colleagues Chris and Cassie they're
going to actually walk you through
the master plan
where we where we got to where we are
now
Kia Ora I'm kessie
um I was quite heavily involved with the
uh development of the master plan
process and
um I'm just going to talk a little bit
about the engagement side of things so
in order for us to fully understand the
Strategic direction for Sandy Point
um engagement was really important for
us to get that right so we had a very
thorough process with multiple partners
and stakeholders we also worked really
closely with monofinoa from the very
beginning and throughout the whole
process as well
and it was very robust and repetitive
um
a big highlight for that was the
resident survey which was sent out to
all the residents and we had over 1500
responses so
um it was just great to be able to get
that that targeted and also making sure
that it reached out to the public far
and wide as well to get those responses
and what people wanted to see
so just a bit of a snapshot that's in
front of you there uh just some key
things that we found sports and
recreation is really important for
people who access the space there's a
lot of appreciation for Native
vegetation and Pest Control
wayfinding and Safety and Security is
also really important to people who
visit Sandy Point
and also we found that um there was a
few comments around sea level rises and
also um
the uh what what else they could do out
there like the amenities to support them
thank you Cassie
caucus bar and I hope uh appreciate the
time that you guys are taking to go
through this in detail what you're
looking at up on the screen at the
moment is the existing situation and
what you'll see is you actually see a
whole lot of discontinuous exotic
forestry operations you'll see 17
different
Club buildings in various states of
repair you'll also see a whole lot of
different Recreation opportunities that
have evolved over time and they're not
necessarily interlinked with one another
you'll also see a significant amount of
eroding Network out there
once again of various State and
condition and so what we're looking in
this master plan is to take this
existing situation and move it forward
so that we can plan for a better future
and the the strategy the overarching
strategy that we've got on the screen at
the moment is really around how do we
take the beach how do we take the river
I'm blocking either end of Sandy Point
domain
with
the biodiversity as very important while
maintaining that exotic forestry and
Recreation buffer so what we heard from
invercargill residents that was really
important is the recreation offering
that is out there we want that to
continue we want to enhance that and we
want it to be an attraction for people
to come and visit
in addition to the recreation offering
it's also that visitor experience that's
really important
that visitor experience at the moment
has evolved over time and isn't
necessarily well connected we also heard
quite strongly about environmental
resilience and having adaptive
Management in the way that we manage
this place over time
so to further explore on those three
themes
enhancing the recreational offering so
what are we talking about there we're
talking about Motorsports we're talking
about water sports Field Sports equine
and canine opportunities the multi-use
facilities that we have out there we
really want that to continue but we want
to lift the level of service that we're
providing out there
um when we talk about uh sharing and hub
facilities we're aligning to our
recreational spaces and places strategy
uh that we've been developing through
active South and across across Southland
itself
um when we're talking about the
facilities that are out there if they
reach their end of life are we
supporting our clubs in the best manner
to continue out there in isolation or
should they be connecting together as a
hub
um and what's what's really important is
there is some underutilized area out
there that we want to develop as as
multi-use
now if the trends that we see continue
this is when we start looking at the 25
and the 50-year vision
and what that means is that we continue
to HUB those like activities out there
so the level of service can increase
we're trying to look at where those Hub
facilities are best located when we
think about the changing River when we
think about the changing Beach and
planting out
when we think of the 50-year vision
and it's aspirational goals what is a
what is a visitor Pavilion look like out
there and so if we flick through the
next couple of slides what we see is the
ideal scenario so we've got these
opportunities out there and we want to
really lift that level of service
now visitor experience this is really
important and what I want to make sure
um that I really want to have a home
here is around how we can better design
this place for a really fit for purpose
visitor experience and so over the next
10 years what's really important is that
we we address the roading Network that's
out there so providing a second access
through into Sandy Point rather than the
sole access that often is quite close to
the river
when we look at the multitude of roading
Network throughout Sandy Point we need
to be quite targeted on how we manage
that
um
we want to really provide that visitor
experience to align with that the native
the requests to return it to more native
state so how can we expand on fosbender
how can we expand at the north of the
domain how can we expand on the native
experience that we have down at the
south of the domain and again if these
Trends continue
over the 50 and 25 year period
that's where we're thinking of looking
at what what kind of opportunities can
we have at the end of oriti Road and so
do we want to have a pontoon at the end
of rd2 road so people can access the
River from there so they can experience
Sandy Point domain from the water not
just from the land and so we want to
continue to look at the visitor
experience out there and if these Trends
continue we may need to consider
how we manage those that roading Network
past a visit of a pavilion and whether
that road adjacent to the river is
viable for the future
so as you'll see over the next couple of
slides here are some key images of what
we're looking to present in that space
well um what's really important for
Sandy Point is the ability to tell a
story about the history that's there and
so at the moment uh the storytelling
that's out there has evolved over time
but we're looking at getting a really
clear story that we're selling out at
Sandy Point to to get people to visit
this place
now to build on the third theme around
environmental resilience and our
district plan we've got areas of
ecological significance and this place
itself is really unique when we talk
about the protocarp forest that's out
there
um over the first 10 years we're really
looking at centralizing that exotic
forestry so any of the current
commercial operations that are occurring
around the southern tip of the domain
when we when that expires then we
actually start replanting with with
Native
well just to increase the biodiversity
that's out there
what's really important to address is
the slash that's left over after that
native forestry and the
um
the bio threats the the broom and the
gorse that also turn up after that so
once again if these Trends continue we
really want to start connecting those
environmental plantings to those areas
of biodiversity ecological significance
we want to expand the wetlands that are
there that to be better fit for purpose
and connect those environmental
plantings
the riparian margins and how we connect
the river to the beach through this
important area is is really important
and that's how we're looking to evolve
the Sandy Point experience through this
environmental resilience
once again you'll see a couple of slides
here around what could be if we're
thinking about Shangri-La if we're
thinking about 50 years time uh you know
what what do we actually want Sandy
Point to look like now if if Cassie goes
on to this next slide it's a there's a
lot of noise on the slide but it's what
I'd call a strategy on a page these are
the three themes together really focused
around that Recreation opportunity
focused around that visitor experience
and how we build environmental
resilience
um what what's the next step here
um Cassie you just want to talk about
that a little bit
um yeah so just briefly the you've got
the existing
um Recreation on the top and then you've
got a visitor experience in
environmental and those
um those first three boxes in the first
tenure
boxes will be the ones that we'll be
focusing on as we uh review the 2012
Sandy Point domain management plan and
then 25 years in fifth year Vision
there'll be the subsequent management
plans when they're under review as well
thank you Cassie are that those that is
really important that the focus is on
the next engagement
one of the reasons this um project was
delayed was we're looking for up-to-date
lidar data to inform what we want to do
at this site and see if it aligns so
what you're looking on the screen is
um what are those one in 100 Year Storm
surges so this isn't what the status quo
is but this is how inundation occurs in
that one and 100 Year storm we've we've
picked a date in the future that's
pretty close to around 2040 and we've
used the same same type of modeling as
we used for uh Steed Street and that
flood protection and so what you're
looking at here is uh sealable rise of
30 centimeters and what does that
inundation mean so it really does start
to build the evidence around needing two
entry points into Sandy Point how we
need to start hubbing those like
Recreation facilities to create a better
fit for purpose use and really start
managing
um the site out there as you can see up
there some places are affected in some
places are not
um the I wanted to finish off with just
showing a schematic on on what does it
look like from now until what I was
saying is 50 years time and so Casey
will move through these quite quickly
but really just trying to start
replanting out in the Sandy Point domain
centralizing that commercial forestry
starting to create those visitor hubs in
those core locations and really thinking
about how we can access the water from
the end of Audi to Road rather than
solely the Sandy Point domain so we can
get that Sandy Point domain experience
from the water not just from the land
I really appreciate your time and we're
really Keen to take any questions you've
got
thank you Tom
I may have two questions Jennifer thank
you
so the first one
um is about already pitch access by
vehicle
and I notice when I look carefully at
the charts that it shows essentially no
change for the first 10 years
by 25 years because that could by by 11
years but by 25 years on the chart
um
the disease new instead of a hard Road
onto the hard line black line onto the
pitch there's never dotted yellow line
onto the beach which means it is managed
now I don't know whether I should take
that as a euphemism before closed
but
um
uh I think we need to be careful that
um I mean Council May support that but I
think we need to be careful that in
adopting this master plan we are not
adopting a presumption of closure of
variety beach by vehicle to Vehicles
unless we actually decide that
um I'm not personally in favor of that
but
I I quite as a euphemism foreclosure no
it's not youth youth isn't for closure
at all it's as you say it's managing it
and it's looking at the management of
that area so it's just indicating that
we're an area that we would look at as
we have done with the rest of the domain
okay thank you same question
um the
my Supply looks completely silent on the
question of Cooper's Creek Crips and and
I think the the fight that we do
actually have Cooper's Creek resonance
here I think it's important just to
comment on that that it's I mean I'm not
going to put what's in your mouth but
that it is not covered because it did
not have to be covered by the master
plan it'd be covered by the management
plan is that the that's correct
constantly yeah okay thank you
Barry yeah I too was going to bring up
Cooper's Creek it's a very important
area there
um but with having the two roads coming
into
um Sandy Point
and we've got enough hoons racing around
there at the moment in the sand
and we're going to have any sort of
security
that we can catch people like that like
they burn cars down there and do all
sorts of weird things so
um particular stepdad issues such as
that will be addressed through the
management plan so the the master plan
again is just looking at that long-term
Vision so any specifics around that
would be addressed through through our
management plan which is where we want
to step onto next
very good thank you
Korea
um thank you very much for your
presentation
um
two questions installed on some kind of
deeply minor Weaver
um in the vision for the master sorry
the vision for 50 years I noticed that
there's a lot of
um
uh
areas defining what's being used what
it's called and then just coming back to
the beach access for the parking with
the engagement that you undertook
how many people approximately we're
engaged with and how many opposed or
supported there to be Beach parking off
to the side
so I'm guess I'm asking like how has it
I think the easiest way to address that
is it wasn't a specific question that we
asked within the master plan it wasn't
one of the specific areas that we
addressed it in that way with that
question so I can't answer I'm afraid
okay
can I throw up a rhetorical question
then and go is it perhaps an answer to a
problem that sometimes the beach is not
an appropriate place to park
when there's a king tide or what have
you and that offers an alternative
the the correct response around the
beach is it it was out of scope of this
master plan um and anything that we do
there's needs to be addressed
collaboratively with with ewe with Doc
with environment Southland with SGC and
and roading so it it was out of scope of
this particular master plan and also
police I guess because it's a public
place thank you Evelyn then may cloak
um yes so there's a few things that I
noticed
um
within the report that I know were
highlighted by by ewe
um and a lot of it is around introduced
pest species so I was delighted to see
that highlighted not so much I know
because this is a master plan there are
no Solutions but I did wonder if as part
of what you're doing proactively now
that
um
because it's been indicated that these
are concerns that there is already some
work being done by parks for instance
with salt water resistant plantings on
the
um Southwest
and all those sorts of things end with
the um
extraction of some of the
invasive species that are around in some
of the
um
fresh water areas
which have been raised concerns about
and in that way are you already
indicating that you're accepting of the
premise of the master plan that these
are things that need to be addressed
under the current management plan we do
have some Pest Management control of
both predatory and ecological
plant species so we are undertaking Pest
Control work already and hopefully we'll
identify more
um more specifics in the next management
plan to ensure that we're actually
targeting the right species going
forward for the next 10 to 20 years
and so as you remove
these lists
um
attractive species
um are you already immediately sort of
replanting with more indigenous species
in those places to give them a head
start that's that is what we are
planning to do yes thank you yeah
Clark
you have a couple of things um good to
notice that my dog that gets purely
losses now wayfinding I was really
pleased about that new terminology
um two things I guess one really good on
the feedback that the ranger needs to
come back
but what isn't there is is that going to
be a residential position again
or not
that would be a gesture management plan
it would have been nice to to have known
that because I get a lot of feedback I
haven't lived out there and we walk dogs
out there most days and the degree of
damage since the ranger has gone and I
don't want to get drawn to the issues of
why he left but I do know that
um
uh it's created us a huge amount of
problems when he's there residentially
he or she is there residentially they
have a presence that people are aware of
so I think a rethink on that residential
location under no covering it's the
issue uh would be helpful the other
issue is the issue of Cooper's Creek
and I think one of my colleagues raised
that and and I'm not sure they got the
answer that I would be now seeking but
on page 34 of board books it says
stakeholders who are licensed who have a
licensed occupy will need to have
documentation restructured until the
management plan has been adopted and
that given the current dispute that
we've had which is ongoing for my
recollection two three years now at
least
it seems a little bit of a heavy hand to
me at least one where the what what is
proposed by that restructuring of
documents because it it sounds like
we're going to restructure the documents
and until we get a bit further down the
track when we have the management plan
that might clarify that and given that
we've got disputes in that area just
would like to know that we're not
heading into another round of disputes I
guess
we're not aiming to restructure any of
those documents immediately because we
are waiting feedback on this disputes as
you said okay thank you there's no
immediate work in that area at the
moment my clock yep that's all good
thank you bring back the bring back the
Ranger
Grant yeah thanks chair um
some questions and some comments um
notice the reference around the two out
Tiara Trail so coming off the end of the
beach and then going across so that's
the original
was the original Trail was it many moons
ago
um feedback from
um indicates that it was yes so that'd
be interesting to explore how we could
potentially
that's a very expensive bread I know
just a thought
um the road closure down the side of the
river what what's it thinking there
um I'm gonna let Chris answer this one
he's a lot better on that technical
writing
so that's what I meant by when I said if
these Trends continue so at the moment
we're seeing lots of inundation in that
location and so what's really important
that was developed through the master
plan is the idea of creating secondary
access so that in times of the one and
100 Year storm we're not there aren't
people out there that are stuck they do
have options moving forward and moving
forward into that 25 and 50 year time
frame if that road is becoming cost
prohibitive to maintain then actually we
can think about different options that
the only way that would occur is through
subsequent management plans so at the
moment it's being raised because uh the
data that we're receiving is indicating
that we need to have different
management options but nothing is
decided it's simply something that would
be developed through subsequent
management plans so just to follow your
logic
we're going from one axis to 2x this is
the One X is over 50 years
well that's what the plan shows
we're focusing on the first 10 years is
the next step yeah but sorry didn't I
hear the argument was we want to have
two access ways for safety and getting
people out over 100 years but we're
going back to a one axis and then we
want options moving forward
okay
um the Forestry
removal how much area
has been in commercial forestry out
there
roughly
I honestly haven't got a rough figure in
my head for you cancer I can bring that
back to you I think it's 200 hectares
yeah and what I'm thinking what would
like to understand more is
you know the plane requires quite a bit
of capital have you done any costings
around the cost of the plan
those are what we'll be working through
with the management plan so the
management plan will give us costumes
for the next three years which will
happen at year four of the long-term
plan but surely you've done some sort of
sniff taste of what it would cost
through the 50 years to set up the bench
Park and Eco Park and that's all in all
honestly the the master plan is not that
detailed it's not got that focus on it
it really doesn't have the focus on the
on the economics of that master plan it
is literally what do we see as a vision
it's not a costed Vision yeah so
so if you purely look at it through a
fine a financial lens the next 50 years
is going to cost a consider a better
amount of money to rate Perth
and I'll answer the sort of lead you to
that path where if we maintain some
level of commercial forestry then maybe
it can be self-funded as opposed to just
being a net drag
on the on the rate payers so I'll just
your first question around is it going
to cost a whole lot more we're going to
approach the master plan in 10-year
segments through the management plan
through the development of that
management plan that's when we start
costing the foreseen actions and
development so
I would not necessarily agree with your
statement that it's going to cost
ratepayers more money you simply don't
have that information yet like Caroline
was going to address it but if you look
at the what you're proposing Around The
Pavilions and those sorts of things I
mean
you know they cost money don't they
the forestry to go back to that question
we're actually looking at it as a whole
is that the where we've got exotic
exotic Forestry at the moment that might
be moving towards being indigenous
forestry which we can also seek carbon
credits for so we're looking at ways of
keeping the forestry out there as as an
economic source
to perhaps not as exotic Pine Forest and
harvesting it so we we're looking to
maintain the funding source out there
but looking at it differently looking at
a more environmentally friendly way
but at 2050 carbons worth zero so
there's no carbon tax there's no carbon
credits
for carbon neutral 2050 carbon credits
worth nothing
it's reality well that's the theory
no there is the real negative of the
carbon model
so I think we've got to think about it
you know it's great to have a master
plan but there will be a cost and look
at the significant value to the city and
in Sandy Point no question my question
is
and another one I had was do we want to
attract more people there
and what's the ecological impact of that
or do we just want to manage the
experience of the people that go there
in a in a cost effective way which is
friendly to the environment but still
maintains the unique values of of that
environment because I know a lot of
people aren't including myself I go
there to be sort of relatively by myself
and to have a pretty sort of unsort of
managed experience
as opposed to go there and try and buy
an ice cream and have a sort of a
visitor experience which might be more
you know
appealing to a national level but I
think fundamentally a Sandy Point is a
treasure to invercargill people and
maybe wider Southland Community but
that's
you know that's the primary purpose in
my mind but I'm happy to listen to other
arguments but it's a real ecological
spatial Freedom Place for the city as
opposed to let's try to turn it into a
more visitor experience and ultimately a
commercial
base just my thoughts and thanks to you
so question around process we're being
asked to endorse officers proceeding
with the management plan two-step public
notification process you want to run us
through those Crystal Carolyn
yep so we are now looking at um for the
endorsement for this two-step process
which will begin
um
30th of September with your endorsement
which have been inviting written
submissions on how with this master plan
how do our community see us actually
putting that into progress and into
place through that the first 10 years of
a management plan
um looking at the summary from the
master plan we were looking at those
submissions on how they see us enhancing
Recreation promoting the unique visitor
experience and also building that
environmental resilience
um so those are the submissions that
we'll be looking for the paper is um
really seeking for us to go forward with
the next stage with the public so let me
help with the with the submissions is
there a hearings process that we go
through or are they just written
submissions that we receive written
submissions initially
which and then when we have a draft we
actually go to the hearings when we have
a draft plan so it's a two-step process
and then when we go out what's that
draft and consult on that is there a
timetable for when that's going to
happen
my learning colleague to my far right
who's Snapchat
but next year I'm guessing oh yeah
you're useful now in the meantime if you
come back to us it would be great
bring it
look I think you know as it's been
mentioned it's one of the greatest
assets we have um with the dog there
every night he takes a possum out every
night
there's no cats out there which is quite
good you could take Grant out as well
yeah yeah but one of the things is that
I've just I'm just a bit worried about
the submission process is that because
it's the master plan a lot of people
would will be submitting on what you've
raised before the management plan
so so we are going to be asking for
submissions on the management oh as well
so the money if you endorse the master
plan
um it will be endorsed and that will be
that's our strategy and then we are
looking forward to actually receiving
submissions on a management plan
right so the public will know that when
they're yes no that's great I just
didn't want to master plan will enable
consultation on the management plan yeah
no that's that's fine because I think
people like getting into that into the
nitty-gritty they do yes yeah
so
your consultation is going to be through
written submission
we've got quite a prescribed
um process through the reserves act on
how we can undertake that so yes it will
be initially so it's initial written
submissions on what people would like to
see in the management plan we then draft
up the management plan and that then
goes out to the public for them to
um to look through to read and to submit
on again on what they what they see
written down so it's that's why it's two
stages we ask for that initial stages we
formulate that and then send it back out
and that's uh the prescribed process for
a management plan yeah I'm just
wondering you know because we see it
through activities report how many
people use
um Sandy Point but I'm not sure many
would actually take the time to put a
written submission in but if we engage
them in a different way through public
and Forum or and you know I don't know
you'll probably go and cheer around
what's the best way for us to engage to
get a really strong well understood
voice for Sandy Point so I think that
comes at the Second Step Chris yeah so
uh the best way to engage is through
multiple different Avenues and so we've
got lots of examples through school
holiday programs we've got lots of
examples whether we want to address any
written submission so it's not just
through one Avenue we want to connect
with as many people as we can so that
we're getting the voice of the community
onto this parcel of land so that we
really have the next 10 years well
aligned to undertaking a delivery of
Sandy Point master plan development that
that matches the need and the wants of
the community so so we will see that
plan of consultation back through this
commit at some stage yes we will yes
yeah just two things I mean I can always
leak out that the kind of convert it
into residential land and then we'll get
about three or four thousand submissions
which would be a good way to do that um
just from your perspective to you we're
being asked to adopt the master plan
today
um and I just want a signal that I
um and opposed to it while that
provisioner still sits on me about the
um about the need to documentation to be
restructured around the license to
occupy which is a Cooper Creek issue
um if we haven't got that resolved we
shouldn't have it on a master plan
because that leaves the door open
I think for a heavy hand from Council
if we if we if we don't need that in
there we shouldn't be there or we should
give them an exemption under there that
acknowledges that we have an area of a
concern
between some current license holders
and that they will not be pressured in
any way under the smartest plan
noted thank you everyone uh I was going
to move
the recommendations
where I'm open to that
so you just the move that we received
the report that we endorse the council
officers to proceed and that we endorse
the Sandy Point domain must please okay
be moved and seconded we've had a pretty
good go as they don't cover the knobbies
uh well from what I heard the mayor say
he'll vote against it
yeah well I'll Channel this year that we
could just take that sentence here
because It suffers Nothing by removal of
the sentence
well can I just clarify
are you talking about the column headed
risks on page 34 because it says it's a
potentially supplication yep
so so that's just notifying a risk it's
not saying anything
no but what it does say there is a
licensed occupy
stakeholders with leases and they're
licensed occupy will need
to have documented documentation
restructured so that's not a we might
get around to it we don't get around it
it's saying going forward
until a management plan has adopted
which is we hear next year sometime I I
read that as a management and mitigation
that was a potential kind of thing that
wasn't a this will happen it's a
potential that would go in what was
consulted on and we would no doubt get
feedback
on on the lines of what you're saying I
didn't I didn't read that is this will
definitely happen I read it as part of
what we would put in their first tranche
is a possible risk possible mitigation
and ask for feedback on have I read a
bit the way I read it that way too to be
honest but I don't think it would suffer
I don't think the report would suffer
any but I simply removing that from the
you know I kind of find it what page is
it again
so everybody called it once again my
page 34 but my worry about removing it
would be you're not giving people the
chance to feed back
including the current residence if it's
not there
you know Trish
weren't we told that this did not cover
because you know that area
so the manage the master plan doesn't
cover the specifics of Cooper's Creek in
that way the management plan will do
the management pen we'll do we will do
and we're going to be working with the
residents of that area yeah and this
Master plane there are there are no
leasings there are no people there it
doesn't it's silent on the issue so why
do we have
there it was a because there is an area
there that we needed to address in some
way
Amir Clark then everyone
help me if I've got this wrong but the
the 12 or 13
um licensed to occupy at least hold us
call them whatever you like out of
Cooper's Creek are in the the zone for
this
yes
that's what I thought too
yeah
see if you can work that one through
absolutely yeah if I can explain that a
little bit what this does is this
outlines a vision there isn't any
specifics that are approved or declined
as part of this master plan it is a
vision it tells us
it tells Council what the
people who contributed to this process
said they wanted to see out at Sandy
Point the recreation offering the unique
visitor experience the ecological
importance out there any specifics
around a license holder or tiratonga or
anyone like that that's managed through
a management plan and that's the next
stage so this is the vision and the
direction that we want to head it's not
the specifics that you're talking about
Evelyn
um yes that was the point that I was
going to raise is that
um Coopers Creek are not the only people
that have licenses and leases and things
like that so let's be really clear this
talks about the sports clubs including
territime and all those things
who may over the period of the master
plan process
have to have discussions about
via site the implications all those
sorts of things so it's not one group of
people it is the whole spectrum of users
who have used user rights currently
Barry yeah I'm just I just wasn't very
worried about the Kirby's Creek
situation so as long as it's not part of
a road on then I'm happy with it
yeah Clark
you know I'm not happy about them
um look after previous discussions from
our money route before about the unease
of the Coopers Creek people
um on Sandy Point and that's the right
to happen I don't dispute that but while
we've got an ongoing dispute with him
we should not be riding in the document
this is not as general as as the staff
I've said and I'll read it again so
everybody can really clear stakeholders
with leases
and a license to occupy will need to
have documentation restructured so
that's not a suggestion it needs to be
restructured until the management plan
is adopted which we heard is next year
potentially so in the interim they need
to have documents restructured now the
documents are the core of the dispute
out there with Cooper's Creek has been
for many many years and certainly from
my perspective of being involved with
this I think we've done extremely poorly
by them and and managing that conflict
so I don't want to add to that to have
something in there that says well we're
gonna we're gonna change the
documentation
around them I don't care about territory
but around them where we've got some
dispute we should not change the the
paperwork I guess the conditions of the
ability to occupy
um while we're in dispute with them so
can I ask this question would it be more
appropriate then for us to change the
wording to main need to have because it
is general labor all these numbers
rather than will because your concern is
that
um you feel that it will require change
whereas I still still wouldn't agree
with it and I'm not trying to block any
resolution to this I've noticed and this
predates the current people sitting at
the top table how Council previous
management
of the parks and reserves have dealt
with the Coopers
Creek issue it's been bloody terrible to
be quite honest that's my personal view
I've been involved on both sides of that
fence and I don't want to leave the door
open for an escalation of the of the
dispute if if what the staff have just
told us is that this is just an interim
step that they don't need to take until
a management plan comes in which will
manage the situation then why don't they
delete it
bring it just from a technical point of
view the way I see it is is the the bit
that knobby refers to
um in that table
is just in the report and we're
receiving the report we're actually what
we're adopting or endorsing is the
master plan and the master plan actually
doesn't contain that wording so we're
actually not a we're not endorsing the
report that is a statement within the
report
um and removing it from the report
doesn't it it's it's done so everything
I see in the master plan if we adopt it
does not
any way you refer to that we're not
we're receiving the report we're
proceeding with the two-step plan and we
endorse this attachment with all the
fancy photos and stuff can I ask it in
terms of the one thing advice through
YouTube uh the sentence because I think
because I was going somewhere else for a
second sorry I'll beg your pardon you go
Michael I'll come back to you Tom uh
three self-tier uh but we have to
provide a risk and assessment in
relation to the report
the report does highlight that as being
a potential risk I do acknowledge that
the word will and may can be altered and
would suggest that is the case in
relation to the report
it does not change the recommendations
because it's not attached to the actual
recommendations the recommendations are
in relation to the master plan and not
that actual report but for uh releasing
this up to the um and Publishing the
paper I would suggest that we make an
amendment in relation to the risk
assessment and change well to May
okay sorry Tom uh I think the sentence
is wrong anyway doesn't it shouldn't it
read stakeholders with leases and the
license to occupy will not need to have
documentation restructured until a
management plan has been adopted
uh the reason why this sentence was put
on is to protect those that are out
there so what yeah but it should be not
need isn't it no because some people
have licenses out there that will expire
before the management plan will complete
and we wouldn't want any unforeseen
outcomes to occur before we've completed
the management plan so wouldn't it read
this stakeholders with leases which
expire
will need to have documentation
restructured
not everybody
that's why it's in May it's a potential
lease implication so that's the risk ID
is the potential
lease implication
so Grant then mayor Clark
oh let's see yeah it's my question's
been clarified through the conversation
so
um
wouldn't we if we've got a set of rules
in place at the moment under whatever
document we've got for Cooper's Creek if
some of them expire and we know that
we've got a plan coming next year why
wouldn't we just have a provision that
rolls over the conditions until we get
to the next master plan and then when we
get to next sorry to the next management
plan so that we have our eyes on the
dispute and try and resolve it before we
Implement a management plan that
actually just surries the water again
and that's actually probably
if you thought about it in a tenancy
agreement that's what would happen it
would just the existing conditions
no that's not so we need to look at it
but in existing conditions would roll
through to the review period yeah if
there's a game between them so that
there's confidence for those that are
impacted that nothing changes until
there's change fluid if there's going to
be change for it so with the water
restructure should the water just be
extended
documentation extended
I'll come back to Michael first through
self-chair I just want to advise
counselor Council in relation to this
the this is assessment of the risk
across all of Sandy Point not just
Cooper's Creek and all of those
contracts could have different nuances
in relation to extension or change of
terms in relation to the the period
between the management plan being
finalized that needs to be highlighted
in there yes like I said we the word
world should be made but it needs to be
it's a risk that needs to be highlighted
to council we would not be doing our
duty if we didn't highlight that to
council there is a risk that some of
those contracts will need and leases
will need to be reviewed extended Etc
during that time frame and that is some
of those recreational users from that
perspective so so can you subsidy subset
them out to be the recreational users
versus the the um residential
leaseholders we would it's just a broad
comment because it's assessing the risk
in relation to that we don't want to go
into specifics because that would be
all the individuals out in relation to
that this is a a risk Clause it's not
putting any action in relation to it
it's highlighting there's a risk we'd
still need to come back to Council in
relation to those in all cases
completely I'd like to suggest well I'd
like to move let me replace the the word
well worth May
well you're the second to say right
that's the Mover in the secondary we are
in agreeance on this matter so you're
changing on
h34 will to May yeah
okay I think we're at a point where
where I want to test the meeting
but I'll let you have a quick response
Lobby
hey look just
as we go forward in the next period of
time with the management plan I don't
think we'll have any difficulty
negotiating a license to at least with
teratoga or whoever but we will not get
easy agreement with the keepers great
people because we have an ongoing saw
that's been going for at least four
years to my knowledge and probably a
downside longer and so how do how are
you in good faith take a a discussion
forward on a management plan which is
what we're going the tool we're going to
use to discuss issues with Cooper Creek
licensees when we know that we've got a
historical
um issue that has gone on for years and
years and years we're just setting
ourselves up for further fights so I I
won't vote unless there's a rollover
effect that we will not touch those
licenses until we get to the management
plan as opposed to doing it now now I
know it's not on the document it's
ranging quite rightly says but this is a
real big steer to start this paper
I think this meeting is as well yeah I
understand that but again at the end of
the day we've we've played some Hardball
with these people
and so I don't want the staff to come
back and say well we put it in the paper
to you
and now we've changed the document we
all keep an open mind but uh well
obviously
just wondering if I could suggest as as
well as the changing the world to May
whether we add a sentence along the
lines of
any such
um
proposals would come back to council
before any
processes were undertaken
yeah through subchi I'm not sure that's
actually required because it's required
for us to bring those back anyway yeah I
know that you'll sit there I'm just
saying if the wording was actually in
there would that make some people around
the table more comfortable
with me for sure
um
then if you want to add that could you
repeat it please so telling you has a
chance to get it down
any such proposals would come back to
count before any
decisions were made
with us for a moment
the Mover agrees with my suggestion
since I'm the seconder
the procedure
just while it's been typed up the reason
that I am in agreeance with this is that
I believe that it may ease some people's
fears even though in Practical terms it
may snow difference to how Council would
have operated it's just quite explicit
rather than implicit thank you
cheer well it's getting written up too
can I come in for those of you who don't
know that there is actually a process
underway and about to start I guess
restart to try to find some resolution
of dishes which
um those license holders have
which involves you know joint meetings
with them
foreign
so the addition to what sits in the
agenda is item four
so note changing the wording under the
risks listed under table two of the
report potential lease implications work
will changes to May
and add the following sentence any such
proposal will come back to council
before a decision will be made just to
clarify with the Mover in the second of
your well I agree to the addition of
item number four
okay thank you
at that point I think we've had a pretty
good discussion so I'll test the meeting
all those uh in favor of the import
resolutions please say aye aye
aye anyone against
from the council table
oh sorry Alex thank you
uh carried thank you for that and thank
you for your patience and freshen that
out
Cassie Chris and Caroline thank you very
much
thank you
but don't go too far
that brings us to tab nine which is the
reclassification of Reserve Land This is
a process that we outlined uh earlier
and is just putting it into effect
or starting the process of consultation
too
change the classification Carolyn and
Chris over to you
um
hopefully taking the papers red this is
largely a unification process for us to
actually undertake the submissions to
endorse and advertise for the minimum of
one month reclassification of the area
of Queens Park which is currently
recreational reserve and reclassifies
local purpose recreational and cultural
buildings and Associated activities this
is to seek your endorsement to actually
take that out to the community
Grant you wanted to move that yes
open discussion ringing
um look one question around the bit that
it says the consultation will be a
minimum of one month look it's been
brought to my attention that
um to comply with the reserves Act and
the way I've read it especially when we
state in our report that this Falls in
our significant and engagement policy
this is deemed a significant decision
um
a management plan the Queen's Park
management plan
3.27.1 any amendments not involving a
comprehensive change of the management
plan should be made by adopting the
procedures specified in the reserves act
section 419 if you go to that if you go
to section 419
it it says that if a council thinks that
okay it
will proceed with Section 6 in the ACT
which says consultation period must be
two months minimum of two months
now the fact that this is a significant
decision
um seeking an answer why we are just
doing a one month
uh consultation when uh the reserves act
would say that we should be doing two
months can you clarify
under what conditions it's deemed
significant for me just to help you oh
no since it's in our own report page
three thank you yeah sorry States under
significance
so
foreign
a little bit on this I think the
confusion was created he historically
went so if you recall uh and I think
it's in the the documents before you
there was on a prior occasion an
amendment made to the reserves act as
part of the consultation around the
Queens Park management plan and that's
the document that is uh the the current
reserves act changes so we're part of
the tennis court was transferred for use
for the museum and that was done at that
time as part of the Queen's Park
management plan changes it didn't have
to be done that way but that was just
the way it was done there are two
separate procedures which can be run
separately or can be run concurrently
The Reserve Act has the the period that
we're talking about in terms of the
consultation the management plan which
will be dealt with at a later stage has
the two-month requirement so that's why
in this document it's talking about just
the one month consultation not the
two-month it's because they're they're
different acts with different
requirements yes there will be potential
implications once the the management
plan is consulted on but that might have
a whole heap of other changes to it as
well
so that's why they're separate separated
out on this occasion but on the last
occasion
because it's suited at the time the two
processes were were put together and the
changes were put within the the
management plan document
answer your question all make sense
and now back to that discussion we had
on finance for City Block so I'll know
I'm lost but
um no I will accept you I I will accept
that explanation we did have a look at
it it is a live issue and which we
identified when we when we came to have
a look at how it would go through this
process and we made sure we were
comfortable that this is the correct
approach no thanks for that I just had
to raise it thank you may Clark
yeah so I've got a range of issues so
just bear with me as I walk my way
through
um
when we looked at the original scoping
of the museum
um who we were told that we could go
down to on the map that's on page
um 139 of board books that we could use
lot one and three so it's a current
pyramid and the adjoining space that
goes roughly halfway along with tennis
courts and in light of that that we'd
need that space we we authorized at the
Tisbury complex
um
and it seems to me now
unless I've lost track of things and
Grant can confirm for me that we've now
got a significant need to go into lot
too so the report talks about
um
about something like 60 of the museum
will now actually go into that space
which is a significant amount of
design work that's either being changed
um or we've shuffled the museum along
because the report says that it says uh
two thousand requested at 2 325 square
meters of the overall seizler Museum
which sits somewhere between three five
and four one
um now needs to be into this new area
hence the need to to reclassify it so
I'm a little bit stuck on that
at the time that we discussed this back
in January this year we gave a clear
instruction to staff that we didn't need
that land but that we wanted it
reclassified anyway for future use and
at the time we discussed the options of
potency extending a museum at some later
stage future proofing it or
alternatively putting an art gallery
there so we just wanted them to go along
um and so I see in the email traffics
I've got back from staff in the last
couple of days they said the executives
I presume that's the executive staff
team made the decision not to do this
consultation until he got the design
um the design details uh which we've
just recently headed he walk it to you
now to me that's a significant risk that
they delayed that because if you think
about where we're going now with the
museum the time frame as we start their
Demolition and in March
and I guess we uh start the construction
I assume in about the mid-year
the physical build starts in so we've
got from now given that we're not going
to do much by way of consultation over a
Christmas period
through the process which includes going
back out to Erie and back out to Dock
and going through The Minister's office
over the Christmas or potentially be on
there and then gazetting it that process
doesn't the report doesn't tell us how
long that process will be I suspect it's
months and months and months
um and gets us right up close now some
of the discussions we've had as a I
guess as a governance group in the last
couple of days
in fact yesterday was well it doesn't
matter because if we wanted to do the
build we could just go down onto the
land that we can do and not encroach
onto a lot too but the logic that I've
been thinking about overnight is if you
started building a museum you're going
to put a concrete a concrete platform
down so we will go significantly into
that and and I'd have sleepless nights
if I thought that we were going to slow
up that
um
that project management team which has
got some very very tight deadlines
because we've just delayed the
consultation on this so I don't I have
issues on two issues why why does the
report say that we're taking sixty
percent of the museum into that Lot 2
area
that seems a little bit odd to me and
secondly while we've left it seven or
eight or nine months to get on a change
it knowing that we're actually going to
encroach into it or is that just an
oversight that we haven't come to
so just a series I'll deal with
the second issue the delay wasn't that a
procedural matter because we didn't have
firm plans that we could show that were
going to be taking place on the land
that we wanted to reclassify and if you
wanted to reclassify it you needed to
show what it was you wanted there not
intent
um so can I just tease you out because I
know you're probably a local expert on
this so if I wanted to uh reclassify uh
TV at Street which we're disposing of or
Donovan Park would we need to have
houses drawn up to show what we're going
to use it for or would we just say it's
for residential use
being mindful that when we asked for
this to be reclassified we didn't
actually have any plans to go on it
anyway we weren't going to use it for
anything other than just make it
available for future proofing
so that that delay just sort of doesn't
quite sit with me
because we didn't intend to use that
space at all
that was the original the original thing
in January was we were just future proof
of
foreign
I guess I'm nervous now that yeah not
knowing what the time frame is at the
end of this report that's the report
says
right at the very end on page
142 it says next steps and they've got
eight steps here
is it a month long well the first the
first step of loans a month and rangi is
suggesting two months
is it three months is it six months
do we have some impact for the project
itself and back in the
the the report it does suggest that
there are potential risks time frame
risk for the for the main project I just
can't understand how we got to this
burger
so the risks that are identified are
potential and you know potentially are
going to be run over on the way to work
and it's acknowledging that some of the
risks will be low but they need to be
acknowledged however let's come back to
your question Aaron
I'm happy to take this one although I
know Mr Cameron's left the room this
will be a one that he'll love as we uh
well and truly delve into different risk
profiles of different options around
this one
um you're you're absolutely correct
around
um question two and the reason around
why we abandoned that um change status
process and that was around us not
having that sufficient certainty around
what uh what was actually going that
space was going to be required for we
did start down that process and as we
progressed through it we found that we
didn't have sufficient certainty around
whether we would actually require that
space because we weren't sufficiently
progressed through the museum design
process to know if we would need to to
move into that uh that that additional
space that didn't have the the reserve
status change on it so that was the
reason that that process was was paused
and we essentially actually just
realized that we needed to move further
through the design process of the museum
to understand whether we actually
required that additional space and if so
what that additional space would be
required for in terms of the time frames
around it we're working on the basis of
this taking between four and six months
for the reserve status process it may it
may be quicker and I'm and it may be
quicker but also keep in mind that we
aren't into construction of the museum
until after that time frame so what may
potentially happen and my colleagues
here have advised us that the the change
processes is particularly low risk on
this one
um but what may potentially happen is
that we would be in the final design
stages of detailed design if we found
that we were going to have a concern
around moving into that additional space
as you'll recall from the design
presentations there was the ability to
not expand the museum out as far into
that space and to pull it back that was
one of the the good things about the
flexibility of that design and that is
something that we could could look at
doing if we did wind up in that hurdle
but we are advised that
um discussions have been had I
understand with Caroline's team and The
Minister's office and we do consider the
risk to be extremely low
if we then go back to that original
question around why we were concerned
about the risk of keeping the existing
pyramid building and then building a new
Museum in that space next to it
the reason that we've seen that is a
different risk viewers because that was
around essentially having an an existing
area of of Queen's Park which is
obviously a an iconic
um Park
um from a reserves perspective and then
keeping that and saying we want to keep
that space we already have allocated to
a museum and then we want some more
space out of the reserve to build
another Museum next to it we did
consider was quite risky from getting
The Minister's office to sign off on
that one
where this process is different is
actually around not encroaching
significantly more into the total amount
of reserve space used but simply around
how to how do we better seat the
building into the reserve so that it
actually has a a better place and better
interaction with the environment around
it so you may recall when you've seen
presentations around the museum it was
around how do we take the green space
that was currently off to to the left
that we're now encroaching into and now
resettle that in front of the museum so
that we're a little bit more set back
from that park space and have the
ability to flow out into into the park
and that's where that's considered to be
a much lower risk profile of Simply
settling the building better into the
space and therefore encroaching into
that rather than taking up significantly
more overall space to keep an existing
facility and then build another facility
next to it as well
so mayor Clark and then please
so um
don't like to have these questions and
open uh an open session but I've got no
choice on it here's your will aware
um
so just quoting back what I was told
there no certainly about Lot 2 as they
progress down the track
um because they were unsure about what
would actually go there because we left
it open for future proofing could have
been an extension to the museum it could
have been
a play area could have been a new art
gallery we just wanted a future proof it
so that we weren't behind the able
for that to be paused and for myself and
Grant and previously Nigel's got to not
be informed of that it's not good enough
because today I've not been told about
that pause
and now to be saying four to six months
which well my assessment takes us up to
April or May very close to the start of
the build which I understand is in June
it's in the Middle East it's an 18 month
build
and we can play around with a month but
given that we've got a change of
government potentially and we've got a
Christmas period as well I don't have
any confidence that we'll have it back
by that period of time so the issue for
me is not whether the minister agrees
and where this is a very simple change
it's just the time frame of getting
through the process
so when you look at those eight or nine
steps that we've got on that page at the
very end which is what are the next
steps
um you know by the time we got a public
consultation which Rangers I don't think
this could be two months not one month
we're well past Christmas
in fact I don't think I should be able
to consult during a Christmas period
anyway if we had a two month commitment
it's probably too late to do before
Christmas and the Lord help us that gets
us into the new year so we're up at Mars
before we've done it then we've got to
provide Doc and full consultation
documents with ewe into there as well
which will follow consultation
um goes to The Minister's office uh we
caught out and and it really hinges me
to be thinking that the design we went
out with which was a great designer has
been well received in the community
could have to potentially reshuffled
because we haven't reclassified or
recoded the lamp which should have been
done six months ago by myself
so a couple of points first of all we're
looking at going out for consultation at
the end of this month
from the documents that I've read yeah
but if we have a two-month criteria
which is what Rings no no no Andrew
corrected it to one month but it's a
different thing I've got a separate
issue to raise along with Navi so as I
was about to say the
um the part that has been reclassified
already across to halfway over the
existing tennis courts was able to be
done because we were showing in version
one plans that went out to that area
uh and and there was no issue
so I don't see that there's a great
difference between
that process that was successful in this
one Leslie then bring it
thank you Mr chair so I'm looking at
page 138
um
where it talks about the concept design
that we all thought was a brilliant
whale fit for design has elongated the
building East-West to provide the public
amenity noted above to the north south
so that's the Landscaping Etc that
Aaron's described in some detail
we all saw that concept design and
thought really exciting great it's yep
elongated East-West but it's going to
give us that additional space
connectivity to Queen's Park and the
rose gardens it's going to give the
increased green borders down North and
South into the extra Landscaping
opportunities so we were all really
excited about that I looked at this
consultation plan and I don't see that
we need to be too concerned about this
time frame because the concept design we
all agreed was only a concept design
we all
pretty much accepted that the final
design would come at a period quite
reasonable for addressing what we wanted
to address to have the exciting facility
we've all agreed on so
I'm not sure that
because as you've just said gear we're
starting the consultation very soon I'm
not sure that we are going to have any
real risk of running into
a problem
by the time we have our final design and
actually start I'm not sure that we need
to get
too concerned about this being
a barrier
I would also note that both in US
developing into that space we did note
um and and discuss
um the fact that we were stepping out
into that space and we would need to go
through this process and we also did
that when we were talking about the
concept design there was quite a bit of
discussion about the fact that we were
going to step into that additional lot
and that we would have to deal with the
reserves process I'd also note that we
also did this for Tisbury as well so um
that was something that we did with the
Tisbury site it was something that was
done quite quickly and efficiently it
may happen much quicker than the six
months that's the absolute sort of worst
case scenario
um but we we've also gone if we do wind
up with that worst case scenario that's
manageable as well
I've got rangi Grant Evelyn and then Tom
now thanks chair look can someone just
give me a bit more confidence around
section 24 of the reserves act and
that's uh talking about publishing stuff
in gazettes and time frames 10th of
January we have had this peer reviewed
that this is the correct process to
follow oh absolutely but can you talk me
through the ACT uh who's who can talk me
through section 24 and what the
implications are
it's quite scary when you read 24. yeah
I mean we're crossing the parts of the
act that are the most appropriate for us
to actually undertake so it's um it
looks nice I'm not a reserves actually
legal expert unfortunately well just the
points that knobby has raised section 24
when you read it is is a bit scary and
this is this where the six months could
spin out I want to give some confidence
because what we're talking about here is
not Green Space so we're not actually
losing lots of Green Space
yeah just looking at section 24 which
you say in your report you uh pursuant
off yeah so I think the risk here is
very low because it's not thanks babe
so if if the legal advice is not here
and the staff have taken the legal
advice and that's what's that they've
written that's fine I don't think
that they are able to spit out the exact
process that you're looking for at this
point Grant yeah thanks to you so just
with respect to the the the footprint of
the museum so and to reinforce what
Aaron said the museum has been elongated
and in partly that's to better fit into
the park and to create that space to the
north of the
experience
building and integrate you know more
in a better way with the Rose Garden
particularly but equally provide flow
through so so the reason for coming into
part
or lot two or the orange area on page
139 is because of that change in the
museum to better fit with the park
the second thing and look with every
process around consultation and
legal documentation I will be going
through to the the minister that there's
risk however
you know from me I get some comfort from
the
classification process particularly with
the reference to local preface look
there's no
to me and in layman's mind there's no
significant change of use here if if we
were looking to put a commercial
um building or sell it off for private
use I think we would get significant
questions from a public but equally from
at a ministerial level you know largely
what we're doing here is
using some park space in a much better
way and you know I have confidence that
we will get through that process pretty
quickly with their public but equally
with
the legal process for our Minister
approval and that sort of thing because
we're actually fundamentally
using space better within within the
park
um so look I hear the concerns that have
been raised by councilman pottinger and
the mayor
some confidence that we
you know this process should move
through reasonably smoothly
okay I've got Evelyn Tom Lynn Leslie
uh Kilda look
I get a little uncomfortable when it's
sounds like Evie might hold up the
process the way I look at it is this
that it's going out for public
notification we're part of the public we
may or may not respond through that but
there is absolutely nothing and I am
reassured to hear that conversations
have already been held with the
Department of Conservation and with the
minister
equally conversations can be held with
us so it's not that this has to wait
until all the submissions are finished
we could be being spoken to as ewe we
could be making a decision providing
feedback that's subject to public
agreement and Council making a decision
you know I don't think one necessarily
has to follow consecutively and take
extra months on top of extra months so
as a scare tactic I I'm really not
very comfortable with that because I
think that this defies the way that
Council has actually been working in
partnership with ewe I'm sure that they
are equally working in partnership with
the Department of Conservation and the
best interests of the city and
if we don't trust this staff to do that
and if we don't trust our partners to be
adequately responsive that says a lot
about us as a group of people really so
from my perspective I'm comfortable with
the time I'm comfortable with the legal
advice that we've been provided
parsing Act of parliament Clause by
Clause is actually a very dangerous
process to undertake when you don't have
the legal degrees to back it up so I'm
not going to go there I just trust that
we are taking good advice that we are
following good process and that we are
working in good faith with our partners
and that our partners will work in good
faith with us to get the outcome that we
all want
I take exception to my challenge of the
time frames I'm trying to get some
understanding of the process be referred
to as
um
some sort of scaremongering I think
that's a really an appropriate statement
and to challenge another counselor who
is asking for some guidance under the
law which we must abide by we don't have
a choice of being inappropriate as well
it's not good enough for a minute from a
member of this Council
I support that I'll uphold you
projection
thank you
Tom
um I mean it does seem realistically
everything that the the risk is very low
that we will not have that in place
before we start construction but
nevertheless in the basis uh scenario
planning
it would be prudent to contemplate that
possibility
and be thinking about how we would
proceed on in that event and and maybe
even you know having having
conversations with have we actually got
a construct again but we're not pointing
it over yet no so we haven't done that
yet
um
if we had appointed a builder then you
know that scenario planning would
include
um discussion with them making sure that
we started from the East and work to the
West rather than our way around
um uh picking up on you know nobby's
comment about you know waking up
thinking about the slab you know
I mean this is far too big a building of
a single poor for the slab I mean it'll
be multiple pools
so as as so I I don't think I mean I get
point but I don't think actually so I I
do think though that we should note in
our minds take the risk of zero I think
we should take the risk is high enough
there are those are involved in it
um and mainly Grant and Lee I guess and
Aaron should be just thinking about what
the consequences would be how we might
guide the constructors so that we um so
that we we can settle that possibility
thanks
as the Mover for the final broadcast oh
it's just gonna address that particular
point
yeah so we we have and we are
end
yeah that Lee's continually reviewing
the time frames and allowing for worst
case scenarios and time frames so it
would put pressure on
um we've tested that through a couple of
sort of meetings and
yeah would put pressure on for sure but
we think we can manage it at the longest
time frame of six months
I think the the key piece to support
that is that we would absolutely have
the design finalized before we started
into construction of the building if we
were finding for some reason
um beyond what we can foresee that that
approval hadn't come through then we
would be proceeding to
tweak the designs to the museum to to
that Western Wing to ensure that it fit
within within the available space we
would not be commencing construction
with the uncertainty of how far to the
West we were going
Leslie I'm I'm reassured that our pmo
office has got it well in hand as far as
that yes
configuration goes but I just wanted to
make a comment about um
section 24 and indeed section 52 of the
reserves Act
um so page 138 so I was comforted to
read
um both those sections under delegation
of the minister of conservation and in
Brackets it says under instrument of
Delegation for territory authorities
dated 12th of June 2013. that instrument
of Delegation is not going to disappear
yeah in the short period where we will
need it so as far as I'm concerned when
I read the references to section 24 and
section 52 and the gazetting
it seemed to me that we had no problem
with keeping to a timeline which
includes delegation from the minister
and an actual instrument of Delegation
that's been in place since 2013 so I
think we can be
reasonably reassured there that the the
legal references written on page 138 and
Page 139
and not causing us to have great concern
about the process from that point of
view or the gazetting of the resulting
notice
at all
crap if the final right of replies to
move no I think we've covered it okay
sorry just the point of order chair
regarding uh councilors opens advice
there are we taking that as formal level
legal advice
no that's what I mean so that as I asked
this question before what does section
24 mean I'm just advising Council that
are we taking this as formal legal
advice from Council sober or as an
opinion and that we yet have not
received formal legal advice
as councilors we haven't
been explained section 24. and the
timelines involved and you know what
there's several acts that are referred
to in the report that you haven't
received advice so the reason why I
asked about 24 was the timelines
understand that and the timeline
question was answered earlier
so
I think it's appropriate to acknowledge
that it is the obligation of Staff when
presenting us with a report to
acknowledge when there is risk
and ultimately the decision around risk
appetite is something that sits at a
governance level
is there no risk that there could be
some potential delay because of some
objection
no there is not
and and that's always been signaled to
us all the way through
so I thank for me clack to to raise up
their legitimate questions but equally
legitimately they are there in the
report
from a resource management perspective
the risks are minimal
but not
non-existent so it's been
a mostly useful discussion
um that said I think the comments that
were made around the appetite
from the public and the response that
have been that's been received to the
plans thus far is
actually the really encouraging thing
and this is essentially the next stage
in helping to enable that and and bring
it to reality
so it has been moved and seconded the
resolutions uh
behind me I'll put the motion all in
favor
aye against
Kerry thank you for that
Southport
and the New Zealand Railways Corporation
Act
sorry have I missed something
sorry have you missed you missed the
boat from uh
I haven't got that yet next that's the
next item
sorry that was don't do that to me
Southport New Zealand Limited
captain
oh sorry there's another one that you're
referring to that comes up in public
excluded
that's a lamington thanks very much with
cream natural not fake
Heather welcome thank you Mr chair
um
this is purely a legislative process
Southport have purchased some land in
the past from New Zealand Railways and
as part of that there's legislation that
has been passed on to that title
restricting how they deal with the land
so that
Southport don't dispose a part of the
land and end up with a piece of a
landlocked lien pretty much how that
works it requires Council resolution for
that legislation to be removed off the
title
Southport uh
um have
advised that they have re-surveyed the
entire Parcels of land into one title
and we'll deal with it as one passive
land which will negate the need for this
legislation process so they are simply
asking for it to be removed
thanks Heather through recommendations
looking for a mover I'll move those and
to shake gee that was quite Tom Barry
thank you any questions for here
procedural matter put that all in favor
against Kerry thank you
right that brings us to the adoption of
the tab venues and it's the tabs and
pokies gambling policy for what we're
going to take out for consultation this
is something that comes up every five
years I think from memory
for three years I think they come around
so quickly I think this is my fourth
Journey around the sun with them
um Rhiannon and Jillian thank you
thank you chair so I'll just speak um
briefly to the report in terms of the
process that we've taken to come up with
the draft policy or policies rather for
consultation and then Jillian you may
speak to just the technical matters
around the thinking lid
so
um we undertook a pre-engagement Hui at
the Mirai a couple of weeks ago it was
an awesome
venue so um it was lovely to be there in
that new space a range of stakeholders
came together
from both the operator side and um
social groups
um in order to look at this issue and
following that pre-engagement Hui we
have put forward these policies
for um adoption for consultation so that
was an informal part of the process but
I think it was really useful in terms of
putting forward a direction that we
think will work well for balancing what
is a complex issue for the community
um so I'll just draw attention to the
three substantive changes that we're
recommending there are a few
um issues relating to the update of the
racing act so that just changes the
purpose of the policy so that's been
updated to reflect that secondly
um following the discussion at the
pre-engagement Hui we're recommending
moving from a cap to a sinking lid
and thirdly
adopting a voluntary code of conduct
which is based on the gore District
Council initiative that they introduced
a few years ago and was positively
received as a potential
um element to reduce social harm
it's Jillian so in terms of the
sinking-led policy what they
what is that if a venue closes or if
um a licensed venue decreases the number
of machines that the
the syncing load will apply for the
number of venues or the number of
machines and they will decrease
we've also allowed in the policy though
for there to be the ability to have
relocations still with within the policy
that would allow relocations to only
happen into the CBD or the business two
zones as per the district plan we've
also allowed for transfers and mergers
to be considered
again they will be linked to the um in
the CBD or the business two Zone
with mergers that would mean potentially
that we would have that we would see a
decrease in the number of venues and
potentially the number of license uh the
number of machines depending on how many
machines there are uh at the venues that
are proposing a merger
thank you from memory the mergers part
of the policy is within an organization
so that's the likes of the ilt or the
southern trust or the lion foundation
and what we are now doing is stipulating
that if you're wanting to shift them
bring them into the CBD which is
reflecting
feedback that we've had interestingly
everybody that was taking part in their
pre-consultation ended up in the same
space so that creates I think a really
strong starting point for us to go out
and and consult with it's always
potentially a motive because of the harm
that some people suffer as a result of
gambling it's also looked to be blunt uh
inequitable because or we can deal with
uh the gaming machines and tab venues
whereas you know our personal devices
have many uh
ways of of gambling that that are beyond
our control
um so it was good to take part in that
pre-engagement and the manner of
discussion that took place we started
off with a um
a sinking lid remained with a sinking
lead then went to a cap and now we may
be going back to a sinking laptop
yeah I suspect I'm going to be swimming
against the teeth a little bit I mean I
I actually don't gamble I I don't at all
um but I've got an aversion to you know
Nanny State type moves
and it seems to me that if you look at
the mass if you look at the arithmeticon
percentages
it suggests that there are about 25
people who gamble in the city
um and if you play the percentage for
those who are problem gamblers it works
a bit 50. so there may be 50 people who
have problem gamblers
and another 24 950 approximately who
just do it for pleasure
um
I don't think that those odds are high
enough that we should actually deny
people the right to gamble if they
watched it
so I don't I don't favor the sinking
lead policy for that reason
um another point I'll make is that we
simply don't know how many of those 50
problem gamblers are simply going to go
and gamble on the internet in a less
social situation then you know set at
home stay on that screen rather than at
least being on a being in public in a
social setting
um
I want to say I guess it's not a
question chair it's more of a comment
but I'm only easy about that because it
just seems to me well sinkingly does
actually by definition a never-ending
process
where you drive it to zero it might take
50 years but you drive it to zero and
if there's 24 950 people getting
pleasure out of it invercargill I don't
know that it's their job to take that
away I guess the option and I don't want
to get into debating it yet because
we're going out for consultation folks
that's when we'll have the debate
um is is that
it would be easy to change back next
time in three years when we go up to
consultation to a camp or we haven't
even decided yet whether it'll be uh a
sinking lid but these are all the things
that that people come forward with um
and it's really up to us to
go out and hear what they have to say if
you've got firm views we're looking for
three councilors and or monofino
representatives to sit on a panel with
delegated authority to make the decision
you've got to sit through the hearings
you've got to listen to the submissions
you've got to read them and if you're
interested I'm interested in hearing
from you
just declaring I'm interested of
managed a problem gambling uh
organizational town in the previous life
it's interesting how you can throw the
stats around
um
if you believe that there are curse that
should be eradicated then you have a
sinking lid pulsing so over time you get
rid of them
when you look at the stats that are in
the report
88 of the profit that come out of all
the Pokey machines if you're in the city
through the trust license and Trust
are they significant
better to have people in venues where
you have good levels of control and I'm
not suggesting they have good levels of
control because that's yet to be tested
certainly around clocks and lighting
um
but um when you consider what happens
with a pokey dollar that you put into
the machine 18 comes off the top so six
goes to the tax man six goes to the
venue owner and six percent goes to the
distribution Trust
which for everywhere else other than an
invercargill licensing trust which has
its foundation which it didn't used to
have back in the day
um and the beauty of of the foundation
is that they don't give back six percent
of the take-backs you get about eight
percent because the licensing trust
itself
takes a greater hit on the on the venue
which other places would not have so
that basically means because they're in
there doing their
normal business they don't have such a
high pressure on me on that six percent
they get as a venue owner so we get a
better return which is about eight
percent from my assessment will recall
but when you do some number crunching
and Tom did some there but when you
number crunch their profit margin on
that eight percent is over eight million
dollars
you can work out what is actually going
into Pokey machines and it's another
watering them out when you consider how
many people play poking machines they're
putting some significant dollars in so
if the pleasure is yes then it's fine
and if the pleasure is you can afford to
play the machines knowing that there's
no winners on those machines they always
lose if you play long enough
um but if that's what people want then
it's no different from saying hey I
spend 20 30 40 a week going to the pub
and drinking which is no different so uh
I'm like also comes with him I'm like
Tom I've come to the position of
um poking machines are not a risk for
most of the population it's only a very
small percent some consider about three
percent of the population are problem
canvas three percent of those at play I
mean not not the general population so I
also support as we get round to having a
rethink about this in England and just
keeping it and then the issue for us is
how do we manage the the people who
provide the services to make sure that
they're in a safe manner okay before I
go to anyone else I'm going to remind
the committee that this is the starting
point there is no point in having the
debate
now
it's about the document that we want to
go out and consult with and get the
feedback that's when the decision is
made
but doesn't the document container
recommendation yes and then what
application is it recommendation is the
recommendation of the council so
recommendation is that's the document
that we go out to consult with and that
we're looking for a hearings panel to
hear them no but as goes as a
recommendation of the council so there
should be a I mean if Council wish to
make that recommendation and it may well
be that others do but I mean it's not
getting in a neutral way it's not going
to provide an auction of a capital it's
going to making a recommendation
specifically about being a sinking lid
but the it's going to be one or the
other let's let's be honest there's
going to be a sinking lid or it's going
to stay out of care
and ultimately that decision is not the
one that was made in pre-consultation
that was what do you think is a starting
point
then we get people fitting into us and
then we make the decision
it might be that people that there's
overwhelming feedback that says no
actually we're happy to stay with the
cap
I don't know
so why not or for the two Alternatives
rather than
because you've got to have one yeah and
if it's not that then it's the other
well we've but we've consulted many
teams we've agreed other things even
today to go to your consultation where
we both adoptions
welcome to place we've offered three
different options yeah one preferred
yeah
and this was just the preferred option
that came from the pre-consultation
if you want to go against the
pre-consultation and suggest that we go
out with a cap by all means we haven't
actually got a motion on the table yet
it makes no difference because if we go
out and say well
council's preferred option as a cat fine
then then let's hear what people have to
say it's there as a matter of interest
to council as to what feedback has been
thus far where it was leaning
question
is there anything that prevents us
getting out with two options
for consultation Brianna we can go out
with two options it just means we've got
to prepare two versions of the policy
um that isn't
too difficult but because of the racing
act changes and a few other changes it
does mean we will need to update
the existing policy that has the cap in
it so it's perfectly possible to go out
with two
and if that's that's where if that's
where the committee wants to go that's
fine we can get a motion that way but it
will need to come back for us to
approve the document of the next meeting
I think if we include in the resolutions
what you want it's not a big change so
I think would be fine
well it seems like we're going to be
having the debate anyway so here's the
list fresh Leslie very Evelyn Rooney
trash no
all right this link thanks Mr chair I
was just going to say apart from saying
that
why did we go out for pre-engagement if
we're not going to go by what we got out
of pre-engagement
um I was not going to get into any
debate at all I was merely going to
indicate that I would be available for
the hearing panel if needed thanks Mary
yeah I'm a board member at the working
men's club we've got 24 machines all
your staff are trained
problem gamblers that are in there so
you're a board member yep does that mean
you have an interest no problem
very useful so we'll stop there all
right yes Evelyn
um mine was very similar to Leslie's and
and that is
the recommendation is actually not
councils it was from the
pre-consultation the people there who
included stakeholders so I think it's
really important that we actually say
that this was what
those people were saying and council is
putting it out to the public for their
opinion
bring it here look
frustrates me a way that is the lack of
the mention of Lotto now a lotto's um
sorry it's not their purvey no it's not
our purvey but no no no no no but the
reason the reason is don't suck the will
to live from the meeting no I'm not
nothing to do with it the reason I raise
it and they talk about gambling harm now
if you're going to use the word gambling
harm of any document that we have you've
got a form of gambling that a credit
card can be used now all of those things
up there are cash
now if you have the ability to go online
with a credit card and put yourself into
serious debt then I I would like to
withdraw the word gambling harm because
you are you actually
it's me it's it's not a true
relationship that's what I'm trying to
get at is that you
you know the harm of using a credit card
that's dangerous sorry you've got
cashier
for these things if you haven't got the
cash you haven't got the cash
Nobby
it's a couple things to reflect on
again I've seen a lot of research and
been involved with quite a bit of
research around the issues of problem
gambling
um
we don't want to kill a bloody chicken
that gives us a egg or whatever the
saying is we get an awful lot of benefit
out of the iot foundation
um is there some harm surely some harm
that small portion of problem gamblers
will move wherever the machines are
they'll search somehow so if we if
before I can say the
um
Newfield was to close for argument's
sake and they've got some poking
machines we want to be able to have the
iot being able to move them
and if we've got control of that which
might be the what the staff are talking
about about the relocation option then
that's okay we can make sure it doesn't
go into a high decile area because
that's a little bit more risky for
people
um and if it comes into the CBD or to
another iot establishment then that's
fine we saw we saw the um
the way the RSA ended and the Wickham's
Club were able to combine and got way
more machines than I would have have
been happy for them to have but it was
managed well and we also know about the
uh Infamous waikiwi shuffle for one for
better words and would hopefully not
allow that to happen again I think the
law has been changed so it can yeah
exactly so look I I think
um there's an awful lot of benefit that
comes out of the iot foundation that
does a lot of Community good that we
would have to fund as a council if we
didn't the only thing that raises some
alarm for me is the level of funding
that goes towards sporting and people
know my sporting background but I just
think it's too heavily weighted in
sponsoring sports teams and not enough
and a whole lot of other things around
arts and other areas and I know that all
the people you cheer because
you've got a finger on that pie finger
yeah exactly so you know look I think
it's positive I think we should we
should try and give the options like
Thomas suggested to the community
because people don't understand that
some people just don't think through
that issue sinking leg versus caps and I
don't think the level that we've
currently got it kept at will do any
more damage than
um then the fact that the problem Gamers
will search out there quite mobile
they'll go wherever the machines are so
if we have a sinking Loop then we're
taking away Revenue that actually does
some good in our community
Peter uh yeah um Mr chair can I ask why
the choice of the 7th of November is the
day for the uh
hearing
any reason no idea is it the fact that
the Melbourne Cup's on that day that is
yes the biggest betting day of the year
and the following thank you for
snatching the headline
and the second Tuesday as a New Zealand
electronic cup which is a very close
behind the mountain cup so either of
those days will be out because you want
as many people to make submission as you
possibly can they'll be there that'll be
the two business days of the year so you
wouldn't have them it's also an
infrastructure meeting
uh no we weren't aware
but it is uh from memory was at 10
o'clock in the morning that had been set
aside you can tell councilors that I'm
not a gambler
um I bet you are the the reason for the
hearings being on that date is just
simply how packed the schedule is and
Liz and I spent many many minutes trying
to work out where we could possibly fit
it in
generally the hearing process only takes
a couple hours and I would say that any
submitter who wants to do a personal
submission has 10 minutes to do it and I
don't really think that's going to
interfere with your betting on the
Melbourne cup no it's the people that we
want to make submissions they'll be
they're so busy at their establishments
that they'll have been they'll have made
submission
yeah but they might want to speak to
them
yeah
we can we'll come back and change the
date for the sake of getting some
resolution we can change we can
certainly change the date
but we would need to just change the
resolution to say at a date at a date to
be confirmed potentially this is not on
Melbourne cup day
all the following Tuesday not the
seventh or the 14th
um I'm adjourning the infrastructure
meeting to show the cup yeah oh
right let's come back to the uh the
issue that has caused the discussion
that's around whether or not we express
a preference for a sinking lid or a kit
at the moment
um the draft
um policy which was going out for
consultation suggests a sinking lid at
the moment I have no motion on the table
cheer I would move in that case that we
adorbed for consultation
we ask both questions as Rihanna has
cleared up that we can do
so we all we offer either
so you're moving wonderful with a
gambling venues policy for consultation
with sinking lead and cap options yes
okay no second day
thank you
just give us a moment Leslie
thanks Mr chair
I'm opposed to that because I just don't
see why
were you ever bothered with
pre-engagement that was a fairly
extensive Gathering
of stakeholders if we're going to say
the pre-engagement meant nothing
yeah well I'm thrilled to have given up
a couple of hours on my son's 21st to go
down and take partner but
it's that's that's democracy we've got a
motion on the table which will come up
in a moment and I'm prepared to to put
it to the test that you either support
going out with with both options for
consultation
or the motion is to feed it doesn't
matter either way actually we'll get
um we'll get a policy up for
consultation but we won't be hearing it
on the 7th of November
perhaps we could ask that they'd be put
separately then or for each each one of
the four
yeah okay so if I take
one three and four with the amendment to
four being
our Barry you can't second it you're
conflicted yes
all right freshers
um
thanks Alex
the amendment to
um we're not saying November 7th at a
date to be confirmed
was that the point
it's real resolution three needs to be
changed too to reflect the sinking load
and cap options
the tab venues policy yeah
okay sorry
oh let's take let's take item one is it
shrinking or sinking
sinking sinking sinking
item one receiving the report put there
all in favor
aye against Gary thank you
items two and three and four now that
we've got with those changes
sorry I need names on item four yeah yep
sorry uh myself
um Leslie Maria are you sticking your
hand up yes thank you anybody else
interested in sitting through the
hearings process oh yeah I will Trish
thank you we can have four yeah
one of these things is not like the
others
okay so with
where did we end up with councilors
Ludlow sober Bond and oil
I'll take them all separately
so the
actually now let's do two and three
together because essentially the same
thing two and three all in favor
all right against no no no show of hands
all in favor
scary
all right
just fine uh and four count Alex was she
did she vote
vote against two and three please thank
you I would like my votes against two
and three to be recorded also
okay
and item four so the three councilors
again Ludlow sober Bond oil
yeah
on a date to be confirmed
okay
December would be a good date I
carried
this is not gonna hold up
right that brings us to the annual dog
control report thanks Rhiannon Jillian
stay where you are
I'll take the report as being read the
annual dog control report is a legal
requirement under the Dog Control Act
1996 and it provides a snapshot of
um activity in our Animal Services
section for the previous year
at this point I'd like to make a data
correction to the report
on
page 188 of board books on the report
under the 2223
um
table under the table where we show the
um the data for comparing 21 22 and 22
23. for the 22-23 year we've said that
the registration population is at 30
June was
8434 that needs to be corrected to be
9351 that change will also carry over
into the uh actual report itself under
the heading dog registration
so nine thousand
nine thousand three hundred and fifty
one that was the registered dog
population as at 30 June for 2023.
if we have a look at the um
the data provided in the report the 2223
year is the first year that we've had
data for several years where there's
been no covert restrictions uh
when you compare it to the 2122 data you
can see that across most of our
different RFS types there is an increase
against 2122 in 2122 we had the August
lockdown so those end various levels of
covert restrictions which has made an
impact on our data and Reporting
I don't have any other comments on the
report if anybody's got any questions
questions counselors ring
thanks chair
um
you said there was about 9 400
registered dogs and do you have a guess
about how many are out there that aren't
registered because I had a feeling that
there's quite a few in town so going
into a registration year we have an
understanding of
what should be registered yeah and that
was
around going into this registration year
that we've just started that was around
9600 right
um
we don't have a good idea of what the
unregistered that we don't know about
population might look like going into
this year we're going to be having a
much greater focus on that
to reduce the level of unregistered dogs
and to get a better idea of what that
looks like in the community okay that's
great thanks Trish on page 191 a board
box about impoundments
I presume because there's about 150
unaccounted for are they put down
um there's 314 and pounded 157 were a
tune and there's only 26
non-released and 17 re-homes so the rest
water are they do they keep them
so 157 were returned under our return
home procedure for the first
offense where they have no history and
they go straight home
um nine were released after a second
offense yeah
um so 17 ring home so the difference
would be anything that any dogs that
were fully impounded and had to be so
the owner had to come and pay all the
fees durable potentially a registration
as well if they weren't registered to
get the dog released there may also be
there will also be
um dogs that were euthanized yeah
remember
so our actual number that would be
euthanized is quite low it sits around
um six percent uh
about six percent of uh impoundments
yeah so under ten dollars
that sounds about right yes
any other questions sorry no that's all
right
um just looking at
the data
um
in the following up on the question
about registered unregistered if you
follow up on
um
these complaints like barking dogs or
menacing dogs or wandering dogs do you
find that there is a preponderance of
non-registered dogs amongst those or is
it just a luck of the draw sort of thing
uh probably luck of the draw a little
bit we might um get a an complaint about
a barking dog and when we uh check to
see the history of that dog in that
property before we go out or make any
phone calls we might find that there's
no dogs registered to their address so
we know that we're also dealing with an
unregistered dog
part of that process would be
um ensuring that the dog is registered
using what we call the seven day process
where we issue a seven day notice to get
the dog registered
that would potentially be followed up
with an infringement if the dog wasn't
registered within the time frames
Maria
um thank you um I seem to recall we've
had a bit of a discussion before about
unregistered dogs and how many of them
are um potentially in our city and I
think
um some of the discussion went around
holding an Amnesty Day where people
could come in and
um
um like Cameron with their dogs they get
them registered but it would be at a
um
reduced price
because of the fact that economic
barriers to get their dogs we just said
we don't want that to hold people back
and of course
then why wouldn't you give that to
everybody yeah well I'm just saying that
with that discussion's been like if you
were having an amnesty you would do it
before you went out into a period of
heavy prosecution yeah yeah that's yeah
I was just mentioning what I sent to
recall that that discussion has been
discussed at one of their meetings
about doing something with it
we work very much with um if people
contact us and they're struggling to pay
um particular school has been applied we
do work with them
we also have a relationship with Jubilee
Financial Services whereby people can go
there and work with Jubilee where
Jubilee will pay the fees up front and
the arrangements so that they pay it
back with them so we have Arrangements
in the place and we do try to work with
people to do that I think that
recognizes the fact that circumstances
have changed for a lot of people you
know as a result of the pandemic or even
just the simple rise in the cost of
living now with the escalating prices
everywhere
Tom
question are dogs
ever euthanized as a consequence of
being unlicensed and failing to persuade
a honors to license them
that wouldn't be a reason for
euthanizing your dog
okay so it's only aggressive dogs biting
is it
never never financial reasons a dog
um
it can only come up to be
I'll go back a step
when a dog comes into the pound
um
the owner has seven days to come and
claim that dog after the seven days
the dog becomes the property of council
at that point we would assess the dog to
see if it is appropriate for re-homing
if it's assessed as being appropriate
for rehoming we will work with our
rehoming agencies to re-home that dog
um
if it's not assessed for being suitable
for re-homing and that would be issues
such as
dog aggression people aggression
then
we would go through the processes of
recommending it the acos would recommend
it for euthanization and that would be
signed off by the team leader
but it's never for financial reasons no
it's the main reasons for euthanizing as
I said would be um animal aggression
people aggression
um or medical reasons
thank you Leslie then ringing I'm just
interested the 42 fail to registers
under Section 42.
do we just find them randomly
responding to calls and then go through
the process or is there a pattern to the
ones who
who have ended up 42 in who have ended
up in that
I'd have to look at the data to see why
um what was behind those numbers I
couldn't comment
without doing some investigation it's
okay just saw a number there and thought
it would be interesting to know if there
was a pattern to it
do they do they always come up because
they have been menacing dogs who have
been complained about or yeah anyway
various reasons that we end up that they
end up on our radar
right
um thanks chair um Barking Dog
complaints
um what is the what is the success rate
and or percentage in resolving
obviously complaints that if you have a
neighbor dog or a dog that's two doors
down
and there's um is not maintained in in
stimulus or is just allowed to go crazy
what what sort of you know what happens
when you can't solve it it just shows
the figure of dog complaints it doesn't
show resolution or success so the reason
I asked this is I've made Three Dog
complaints this year for barking dogs
and two of them are still outstanding
so we start off by working
um with the complainant to understand
what the issue is are there particular
times of day we will and the acos will
ask in a series of questions to
understand what the issue might be
within usually work with the owners to
resolve the issues
we have quite a high success rate with
that
um
Sometimes they come to the point where
we end up working with the complainants
to work and we use bark logs to
determine the issues if it's ongoing or
there's multiple complaints
from the backlogs we use that to do our
own monitoring based on the the times of
day where it seems to be an issue if
those if that's outside of normal
working hours we'll use our contractors
to do monitors as well and we continue
to work from there worst case scenario
is if it's been substantiated then we
would issue a notice requiring
um
the backing to be abated we might make
various recommendations about how that
could be done
it can get to the point that an animal
can be removed from the property
if it's not resolved we do rely very
much on complainants to continue to
inform us when if the issues are ongoing
if we
if we have a complaint and we work with
the owner and the complainant and we
work through that process and we've and
it's been resolved at that point we
don't understand that the issue is
continuing if we don't continue to
receive ongoing complaints okay no
thanks for that
thank you any other questions comments
or feedback if not I'll move that the
report is received and we adopt the
annual dog control report
Evelyn but they're all in favor against
Kerry thanks for your questions on that
which brings us to the activities report
does anybody have any specific areas
they wish to ask questions on
I would like to say something
please absolutely I'd just like to say
that
that really great efforts of the people
who were cutting down the trees who
donated them to a school so they could
use some wood carving I thought that was
a very good PR thing and a good thing to
do thank you it's you know a substantial
piece of uh lumberjacking that's going
on in Queen's Park and nice to see that
it's been well received yep
was that just a wipe of the eye or I'm
just watching an emotional moment or
very proud moment
thank you uh otherwise the
recommendation is that we received the
report
it's very second to Tom put that all in
favor against Carriage which brings us
to the end of the open meeting thank you
to those of you who are online for still
being there and